Miguel Goncalves: Miguel.
GG: Miguel, all right.
You're going to stand right here.
So when you're moving your arm like this,
your brain is sending a signal down to your muscles right here.
I want you to move your arm as well.
So your brain is going to send a signal down to your muscles.
And so it turns out that there is a nerve that's right here
that runs up here that innervates these three fingers,
and it's close enough to the skin that we might be able
to stimulate that so that what we can do
is copy your brain signals going out to your hand
and inject it into your hand,
so that your hand will move when your brain tells your hand to move.
So in a sense, she will take away your free will
and you will no longer have any control over this hand.
You with me?
So I just need to hook you up.
(Laughter)
So I'm going to find your ulnar nerve,
which is probably right around here.
You don't know what you're signing up for
when you come up.
So now I'm going to move away and we're going to plug it in
to our human-to-human interface over here.
Okay, so Sam, I want you to squeeze your hand again.
Do it again. Perfect.
So now I'm going to hook you up over here so that you get the --
It's going to feel a little bit weird at first,
this is going to feel like a -- (Laughter)
You know, when you lose your free will, and someone else becomes your agent,
it does feel a bit strange.
Now I want you to relax your hand.
Sam, you're with me?
So you're going to squeeze.
I'm not going to turn it on yet, so go ahead and give it a squeeze.
So now, are you ready, Miguel?
MG: Ready as I'll ever be.
GG: I've turned it on, so go ahead and turn your hand.
Do you feel that a little bit? MG: Nope.
GG: Okay, do it again? MG: A little bit.
GG: A little bit? (Laughter)
So relax.
So hit it again.
(Laughter)
Oh, perfect, perfect.
So relax, do it again.
All right, so right now,
your brain is controlling your arm and it's also controlling his arm,
so go ahead and just do it one more time.
All right, so it's perfect. (Laughter)
So now, what would happen if I took over my control of your hand?
And so, just relax your hand.
What happens?
Ah, nothing.
Why not?
Because the brain has to do it.
So you do it again.
All right, that's perfect.
Thank you guys for being such a good sport.
This is what's happening all across the world --
electrophysiology!
We're going to bring on the neuro-revolution.
Thank you.
(Applause)